[Music]
this episode is brought to you by magic
spoon I love these guys and I love their
products magic spoon is a brand new
cereal that is low carb high protein
zero sugar it tastes exactly like your
favorite cereals from your childhood
it just doesn't include all the bad
stuff that's the gist
so especially these days when I'm
looking for fond associations good
feelings you know back in the day when I
was before school watching scooby-doo
and eating these cereals that would
leave my milk some sort of
phosphorescent color those were good
times and now I can eat this cereal
which I haven't done in decades but I do
now regularly because let's face it
beans and pasta gets old after a while
so variety pays off each serving has 12
grams of protein 3 grams of net carbs 0
grams of sugar and only 110 calories
it's also gluten free grain for each soy
free GMO free basically all the things
that you don't want free and it's
delicious comes in your favorite
traditional cereal flavors like cocoa
frosted and blueberry you can try them
all by getting a variety pack at magic
spoon com forward slash to him and the
way I found out about this was actually
through a number of my friends one of my
friends and one of this podcast most
popular guests dr. peter tia has crushed
and I've seen this on Instagram and
elsewhere 6 to 7 servings of this at a
time that's a lot of cereal with no
glycemic response in effect his blood
sugar remained flat he was so impressed
with the results of his self experiments
that he ended up investing in the
company that's true for to other friends
as well Kevin Rose and Ryan holiday so
check it out see what all the buzz is
about you can go to magic spoon dot-com
forward slash Tim to grab a variety pack
and no need to take just my
word for it magic spoon has received a
lot of attention since launching last
year Time magazine included in their
list of best inventions of 2019 and
Forbes called it the future of cereal
and my listeners that's you get free
shipping direct to your door so you
don't have to go out to buy this and a
100% happiness guarantee so if you're
not a fan if you don't love it they'll
give you a full refund no questions
asked just use code Tim I've been
stocking up on this and I know bunch of
my friends are as well so check it out
magic spoon dot-com forward slash Tim
one more time that's magic spoon comm
forward slash Tim and at the very least
check it out for a really really
well-done website but the product is
even better than the website I promise
you that so check it out this episode is
brought to you by shipstation I've been
super impressed with these guys
shipstation is the shipping software
with the most five-star reviews now
speaking as a former ecommerce CEO back
in a previous incarnation when I was
shipping tens of thousands and then
hundreds of thousands of products this
is what I wish I had way back in the day
as folks adapt to this changing world
these strange times we were all going to
be buying more stuff online than ever
before and if you're an e-commerce
seller or if you want to be selling more
online you have to ask yourself are you
ready to meet the demands of our new
delivery economy you can be ready with
shipstation
and lots of my friends use them so why
shipstation
when you're selling online getting a lot
of orders out fast can be super hard
I've experienced this firsthand how do
you keep track of who gets what which
shipping carrier should you use how do
you process refunds how do you process
returns how do you do all of that are
you getting the best rates shipstation
helps online sellers of any size get
orders out quickly save money on
shipping costs and keep customers happy
they do a few things really really well
you can import more orders from more
places so no matter where you're selling
Amazon Etsy Shopify eBay your own
website wherever shipstation brings it
all into one simple
interface making it really easy to
manage from any device including your
cell phone your smartphone you can
instantly rate shop your favorite
carriers and this is a huge deal as a
shipstation user you can get access to
discounted rates that are typically
reserved for much larger companies like
fortune 500 companies that meet certain
minimums just as an example shipstation
just negotiated a new deal with ups in
which rates are discounted as much as
62% that has a huge impact on businesses
and on your bottom line your profit
margin and an amazon prime world where
people are used to free shipping small
businesses or smaller businesses can
struggle to stay competitive with high
shipping costs shipstation can help with
that you go way beyond ordinary tracking
so there's a self-serve portal for
people who want to know where their
order is when they're going to get it
etc returns ditto
self-serve it just makes everything
easier that's why shipstation is the
number one choice of online sellers
today you ship more product and less
time with the best rates available and
right now my dear listeners you can try
shipstation free for 60 days when you
use offer code tim TI m there's
absolutely no risk you can start your
free trial without even entering your
credit card info just visit shipstation
dot-com click on the microphone at the
top of the homepage and type in Tim
that's shipstation comm then enter offer
code Tim shipstation
dot-com make ship happen one more time
ship station comm click on the
microphone at the top and type in Tim
that's me t IM check it out
hello ladies and germs boys and girls
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
quarantine Edition where it is my job
every episode as we know to interview
and deconstruct world-class performers
of all different types disease out the
habits routines and so on tactics that
you can emulate apply tests in your own
lives this episode much like many recent
episodes is going to be a little unusual
because of its various points of focus
but my guest is I suppose on some levels
also unusual but a friend of mine who's
been on before that is Esther Perel
psychotherapist and New York Times
bestselling author Esther Perel on
instagram at Esther Perel
official that's es th ER PE Arielle is
recognized as one of today's most
insightful and original voices on modern
relationships fluent in 9 languages that
is not me miss speaking 9 count'em 9
that's all of your fingers -1 she hums a
therapy practice in New York City and
serves as an organizational consultant
for fortune 500 companies around the
world her celebrated TED talks have
garnered more than 30 million views and
her international bestseller mating in
captivity subtitle unlocking erotic
intelligence has been translated into
nearly 30 languages her newest book is
the New York Times best seller the state
of affairs rethinking infidelity as
there's also an executive producer and
host of the popular podcasts where
should we begin and housework you can
learn more about her at Esther Perel
calm or by following at Esther pearl
official on Instagram you could also
hear my first interview with Esther
which ended up being one of the most
popular episodes of the year at Tim top
log forward slash Esther that's es th ER
and without further preamble Esther
welcome back to the show I didn't know
that our first conversation together was
so cool ooh that's nice to hear so it's
nice to be back it was you're an MVP and
I want to give people some context to
place us in a certain time certain
places because we were chatting before
we started recording and you were saying
that I'm catching you at
at a raw moment and I think a lot of
people are feeling that way to different
degrees could you just tell us what
today looked like for you and perhaps
how you are feeling how we are finding
you right now Before we jump into the
questions and answers and so on hmm it's
it's been actually a day not unlike the
days that I've been here in quarantine I
do all my therapy sessions online I am
seeing couples in quarantine all over
the globe families in two three
generations of families in a home
together people navigating divorce and
separation and the shuttling of children
in the midst of lockdown and it's a it
you know it's not that I haven't done
online sessions it's just that an entire
day in people's living rooms bedrooms
cars the places where they try to find
some moment of some space for privacy
it's it's intense then I had a
supervision session with 23 practicing
clinicians talking about what's
happening to them how is our work
changed what are we hearing in our
offices what are the main themes how are
we taking care of ourselves while we're
taking care of others how much volunteer
work we're doing with people who you
know cannot pay for therapy anymore
etcetera and then I did a session just
before you have a couple with the
teenage daughter of which she's in
Germany and they've been living apart
he's been in Italy redzone and she
basically told him to come back within
two hours he was on a plane and and
that's it for the first time in a year
they're living together for three weeks
and locked down and and interestingly
it's giving them an opportunity to
actually work through some of the things
that the long-distance relationship had
conveniently made and in a way managed
to not make them deal with and you have
silver linings you have these
opportunities in the midst of
constraints so that's been my day so far
and then commutating then starts the
Inquisition the interview I'll try to
make it as sort of user-friendly as
possible hopefully this because I know
you'd have good questions olfin and you
audience as well and and I just thought
it cannot be the summary of the day at
the century of thoughts of the last two
weeks for that matter yeah yeah I've
been looking forward to this
conversation as well and I know we had
to reschedule
due to some of the chaos on my side also
so I appreciate the flexibility and I've
really been looking forward to it I'm in
quarantine I am with my girlfriend and
my dear dog and we've been in quarantine
for more than four weeks now and that's
partially because I have pre-existing
pulmonary issues so I've been
exceptionally cautious but nonetheless I
think that many of the questions that
will be asked are questions that I would
have asked you over a bottle of wine
anyway so I'm looking forward to the
conversation and I suppose before we
jump into some questions that I have in
questions from my audience I would love
to just hear from you what patterns
you're seeing in interacting with so
many couples in quarantine so many
couples who are either together and
facing challenges apart and facing maybe
a different set of challenges what are
what are some of the things that you've
seen perhaps that are noteworthy or
surprising to you I think that when
people live under acute stress or when
people live with prolonged uncertainty
or what I would add this week which I
probably would not have been so keen to
talk about last week is when people are
experiencing a growing sense of grief
that they are living with grief for the
loss of normalcy grief for the world
that they've known grief for a future
that they thought they could imagine and
that a currently can't in all these
situations tensions rise and it
exacerbates the differences that are
already existing between two people and
particularly their coping styles so
people are either coming in to my office
and our offices I would say in general
with feeling more together in with their
efficient complementarity there is a
good kind of merging of the differences
in styles or they can be more polarizing
and each one is kind of looking at the
other person's way of handling things as
as a threat you're going out is a threat
the way that you are not being careful
the way that you are being able careful
is funny it's less funny at this moment
that I mean it's funny every day that
answer will change at this moment but
you know I can't read one more piece of
information you know here is another
piece I just read you want to listen to
the latest episode of that and and the
other person says I am you know an
account account in Gurjit 8 any more
information what you often get in this
when you have this kind of uncertainty
in front of you is that people can argue
as if one of them is sure and it's a
kind of a fake certainty in the face of
uncertainty and unknown that you will
hear in couples that's one major dynamic
and then you have I think one of the
more interesting things that I would
describe is what it's been called in the
disaster literature the principle of
continuity and the principle of
continuity is that when people are faced
with the kind of situation that we have
right now it covered 19 and ended in
this mass loss of safety and security on
a global level people divided along
doors who emphasized routine and
also emphasize emergency those who are
trying to preserve the consistency of
their life as best they can and those
who are in coming upheaval and that
everything can change those who think
the structure matters the kids should
continue the rules the schedule should
stay in place and those who are twerking
the rules because the world is nothing
like it was a week ago and so what's the
point of maintaining that structure
there's a whole new normal and that
distinction under the principle of
continuity is is a very useful concept
to look at how people deal with the
situation this I mean I can go on but
then different explain this concept
bulimia let me stop right here the
worldís provides us with plenty to chew
on and thinking about and I would
imagine like a lot of people who are
listening these images these scenes from
my own life or popping up as you're
giving these different examples and I'm
asking myself am i a or MIB or am i both
depending on the day and I would love to
hear feel free to take this in a
different direction if you like but if
if we're looking specifically at this
concept of and could you just say it one
more time I remember continuity but the
principle of continuity is that it can't
remember the exact phrasing that you
used but if you have those who want to
maintain continuity in those who say to
themselves and perhaps those around them
the rules have changed the new normal is
not the old normal it doesn't make sense
to continue with say the kids trying to
follow the same lesson plan they were a
month ago or two months ago if you think
to your own experience if you call to
mind a couple you've spoken to trying to
navigate this and finding friction
because they have these two different
styles what do you do to work with them
what types of questions do you ask or
how do you try to help them find some
degree of harmony with such seemingly
polar opposite positions I mean the
first thing you do here is you basically
provide
with a framework and you tell them this
is what is often called anticipatory
trauma or anticipatory grief that sense
you know a foreboding it we're a little
bit in a horror film in the beginning of
a horror film in which the set has been
set up and the cast and the characters
have been outlined but the action hasn't
started it's just about to start and
until now there was more of an option
for denial and people could just because
it's a it's you know we are it's so
difficult for us to imagine an invisible
danger in danger usually is something
you feel and see it's a threat and
therefore your reptilian brain reacts at
the danger that you don't see it's very
hard to make people change their entire
life in relation to that so the first
thing i said as i normalized i tell
people this is what happens they would
run a disaster you know there's the
there's four stages there's the warning
there's the planning there's the actual
event and then there is the aftermath
you for example you were very active
during the warning and many people kind
of looked at you like strange what is he
talking about you know he's just or
hyper-vigilant etc and then they caught
up with you
some of them during the morning and some
of them may catch up with you in the
next phase so I give a framework and I
say this we there is a literature out
there this is not the first disaster
this is not the first epidemic this is
not the first natural disaster you know
and and in some way it kind of
highlights a perpetual rule which is
that we are all vulnerable to being
randomly exterminated at any time you
know and it can this time it's a virus
so it could be a war or an accident I
mean it really puts us in touch with
that which we may not be able to control
so I talk about that
that comes from that and in many couples
one person is actually more in touch
with that sense that they have a
structured protis full proactive
approach and they often will then see
the other person as more passive and
more fatalistic you know for example I
remember working you know with people
who had been in their apartments during
the Gulf War and they were discover tax
and they would put their gas masks on
and so you had some families where
things were very clearly organized
everyone had a role the anxiety was
really managed parents know where to put
the mask on who and then you had other
people who basically said if the Scud
hits the building the building falls
anyway so what's the point and they had
this kind of what would have been
perceived as indifference but in fact it
was probably an expression of such fear
that in fact ilysm that they didn't
really get into gear I think I hope for
example that your girlfriend and this is
really a classic in some situations one
partner was laughing at the other one
stocking up and in some situations one
partner basically said I'm so freaked
out by that I can't even get my head
around it so I really thank you for
preparing this for us I was I was very
very lucky that my girlfriend knows how
closely I tracked data knows that I very
very very good sources of information
and was willing to with with some
hesitation of course because all of her
friends were calling us completely
insane
follow my lead and we were able to work
together but that's at least at least in
my peer group and my friends that's
that's been reasonably rare there's
there's been a lot more friction I think
it makes it a lot easier for us that we
do not have kids
there's no school there's there are
fewer variables like that to complicate
things so it was on some level I think
easier for us without any dependence but
it may be easier on the practic
sigh right it may be easier because you
don't have like this morning I was
talking with my colleagues one of them
you know she does her sessions in the
car she has three kids at home that she
needs to school and she needs to cook
and she needs to manage to hold private
practice and she needs to have a minute
maybe to herself it's like you know and
the other one was basically you know
she's also with a small one and and she
found his magician who was willing to do
these sessions online and she has a
grandmother in the Ukraine and another
grandmother somewhere else and she's
basically doing babysitting with the
grandmothers online it's just an amazing
set of situations like this but the
deeper question of how people deal with
fragility with the unknown with with
with mortality with grief with with
uncertainty that is not different
because you have kids or not kids even
though you know this I just did this
session with a Sicilian couple for the
podcast where should we begin and she's
a midwife she goes everyday to the
hospital she delivers babies she has to
report in in Italy a midwife is part of
the medical system and she comes home
and if a person comes in with fever I
mean she has three young children in the
house and he's thinking you know what
are you bringing home he's taking care
of the kids he so you have the practical
piece but the existential piece is that
he's thinking what is the world that I'm
raising my children in and then I say to
her do you share his despair and she
says no because when I bring a baby into
the world I still think it is this
magnificent miraculous moment and I
think it's tempting to stay focused on
the practical stocking up you know
preparation piece here and then the
washing of the hands all the other
consignments that we have received I
think it's much deeper when you engage
with people in a conversation about loss
you know about so continuity for example
when I think of the principle of
continuity
and not Yellin my friend in Israel
actually is the one from whom I learned
this it's divided around treating so one
is role continuty right it's basically
the way that the structure the structure
the way that you do tasks that you solve
problems can you like you you have a
you're a data person and you have
continued to read data and that is part
of your role continuity but the second
level of continuity is the relational
continue it is really basically how
people stay in touch there is nothing
that's gonna help us more in this moment
than social cohesion and mutual support
so how do people stay in touch you know
not everybody is is in a harmonious
situation of relationship some people
have to go home 3,000 miles away back to
a family from where they fled because it
was so violent and and unhealthy and and
other people are living by themselves
and so relationship and the third
continuity which i think is really the
interesting one here is what is called
the historical continuity it's it's the
stories that we've grown up with you
know the the stories from our indigenous
traditions from our families from our
religious backgrounds culture that have
told us how people have overcome
adversity stories of vulnerability and
triumph that we grew up with that
existed in our family and that a kind of
transitional pathways we call them to
help us in this moment so that we can
imagine a future and this is where I
really find a lot of people you know
have you had other losses
have there been moments in your family
heavy Affairs your family experienced
other disasters have you ever
experienced this kind of cataclysmic
moments like this one of my you know I
mean and one of my moments I can tell
you super personally it's like I grew up
you know with this Holocaust survivor
parents and their whole group and there
was all these conversations about how
did they know when to leave Germany
those who left how did they know it was
time to go you know and my kids you know
at some point
as discussed with them coming home not
coming home they're 23 and 26 you know
and and at one point I said to one of
them who wanted to go back to town to
New York City and I said look from where
I come from you know I would not be able
to live with myself that I let you go
back to the city my whole life I grew up
with this story of you know they could
have left and they didn't you know but
maybe he's right and it doesn't fit the
current reality but this is one of the
historical continuity that lives inside
of me from which I am organizing my
reality so I've been away for two and a
half weeks to not as not as soon as you
but sooner than others how did you
handle that situation with the with your
child wanting to go back to New York
City what was the after you said that
left he said I know this is your story
but I and he's very careful and I said I
will be better off at home I am trying
to finish college on top I know this is
a kid whose second day of kindergarten
was 9/11 and his final semester of
college is coronavirus so he's
bookmarked with historical events his
whole education and seriously and we had
this whole conversation and in the end
he's 23
you know I 23 was making my decisions
too and in the same way that some of us
have 18 year old parents who are making
their decisions and are not listening to
us and not me but others he went back he
went back and you know that's that we
are it fell we talked every day and I
have another one in London you know it's
not the most explicit I did bring him
out of New Orleans I did succeed in
doing that I said you kid not know at
least come come up north you know not
because I am sure that I'm right that's
the other thing I said I don't know if
one is better than the other I just know
the place from which my fear and my
decision making process at this point
emerges and all your residents fears all
those fears that live inside of you that
I usually nicely tucked away that I
promise you they will come
in situations like this it's the residue
denote the attic opens up yeah
I've I've personally definitely noticed
that where there have been moments in
the last few weeks where my response has
been so strong and or a certain sort of
high frequency stresses lasted so much
longer than I would expect
given the inputs that the only way I
could explain it was this is coming from
somewhere in the past there this is some
type of echo I tried I tried and I did
have some assistance with some of this
which we can talk about if you'd like
but may get into tricky territory if we
went on a journey for you yes yeah well
we'll leave it at that and I identified
a memories from this specifically
relates to shortness of breath and
tightness in the chest and acute fear
related to that and I did have a fever
and shortness of breath and a dry cough
for a period of about 36 hours a week
ago so there was a period of time
leading up to that culminating with that
that have that put me in a very
significant state of duress and my best
guess based on what I was able to gather
from my own memories is a childhood
asthma difficulty breathing caused by
some pre-existing pulmonary issues
effectively ending up last in something
we have in the u.s. called
or we used to have called the
Presidential Fitness Test where you'd
have to run a mile and do these various
things and I would always come in close
to last and I would just feel like I was
about to die and also specifically this
memory that I had of waking up in the
middle of the night when I was let's
just say somewhere between 7 and 10
years old being unable to breathe and
just for whatever reason
being unable to breathe there was a lot
of mold and a lot of allergens in my
house growing up for a whole host of
reasons and I woke up unable to breathe
and was only able to breathe for about a
minute I burst into my parents room as
an old a knight and couldn't say
anything couldn't breathe couldn't do
anything and then it suddenly just broke
and I was able to breathe but it was at
the point of blacking out basically and
I don't know if that's a causal factor a
one-to-one causal factor but it seems to
be some of those experiences seem to be
lending themselves to magnifying certain
things now that's my working hypothesis
I don't know that you need to code it a
causal factor it's an embodied memory
you know and we have explicit memory and
we have implicit memory right so the
expression areas you kind of you
remember you can it's conscious the
implicit memory lives in your body it's
not necessarily if you articulated and
in and in words but then you know this
thing Rises and comes toward you and it
activates the embodied memory and you
people are having dreams people are
having nightmares and people in journeys
are uncovering all kinds of things I
mean I am surrounded by that and it
makes total sense because that it's the
personal historical continuity if you
want in it it's what connects you to
prior experiences of powerlessness of
loss of control of of mortality of of
constriction you know constraints in the
metaphoric sense not just the I mean the
breath is the basic of basic you know so
I'm not surprised am i and so if you
asked me what I would say with people
it's this the first thing is you you
elicit the memory you normalize it you
name it I give a lot of I'm giving names
to things so that people can have a
vocabulary with which to then talk with
the people around them
and I'm going I mind the stories that
people have that people carry inside of
them you know like what was told to you
afterwards by your parents about this
event how has this event been described
in your childhood
afterwards could you run us through an
example perhaps or just use a past
experience past client a hypothetical or
what I just said to show how this might
be applied I don't I don't actually
recall what my parents tell me for
example you know a lot of the people
that you know what we call pre-existing
conditions rather people who experience
themselves as at high risk young people
even you know the way you described by
your family by your fear I mean you've
just exactly described it when you
talked about the running you know did
you grow up with an image of yourself as
I'm not athletic physicality is not my
strength you know that's not my mind is
stronger than my body for example or you
know my mother for example always
described my brother as he was the
fragile one he was the sickly one you
know people those words become a part of
your self description for a while until
you change it it's not etched in stone
but it lives on for quite a long time
you know I have an image of myself as
robust you know but I also think that if
ever something was to hit me it will
knock me over I will not have small
boo-boos you know I didn't have big
things and I mean I I can put myself in
the seat of patience for a moment psyche
i I have I live with that idea that
things can disappear overnight it's part
of my history and that you can just
today you're walking around that's the
descriptions during this day yesterday
he was still running in the park and you
know here he was and he's gone and it's
like it goes so fast it doesn't fit and
so I have that image I think of myself
as someone who yesterday will be running
in the park and today will be going
what am I doing with with people I'm a
lot of the things I do have to do with
writing letters to your parents this is
the moment if you've got things to say
you get the same and don't wait you know
understand that some of your parents who
are much much older and have gone
through all kinds of things in some way
I've may be less scared of dying than
boomers and Millennials in some
interesting way their finger at some
point everybody must go that they may
have experienced other adversity that in
some way makes this not necessarily the
thing that is frightening them the most
or that they have gone through other you
know epidemics earthquakes tsunamis you
name it and they have dealt with loss
massively and they know that you
continue living afterwards so they're
not willing to stop playing golf or to
stop playing cards or to go indoors and
you're like you know putting your hair
but they're not necessarily listening I
am talking with parents about how to
talk to their kids so it's a range now
we're going in all ages of children so
you have the let's start from the older
you know the the first of all if you're
going to go back home and you already
are an adult you need to understand that
many times family visits are processing
you know I experiences of regression
just so you get used to that you will
feel like you were an adult until you
entered the house of your family and
then so I talked with them about that
about how you're going to not turn this
now into a moment of having to prove
that you've really grown up if I could
just pause you for a second it makes me
think of the very recently late Rob
dasa's quote of if you think you're
enlightened to go spend a week with your
family I mean it's like you know people
I tell you I went home it's like I
didn't want to listen to me and I
brought all this stuff and they don't
want to wear it and I'm like you know
it's it's very granular you know one
comes home and the only wants to talk
about is being with his friends and end
of
the parents are like all upset because
he doesn't want to and I'm like no no
instead of feeling rejected that he
doesn't want to be with you this is your
perfect moment to talk with your kid
about the importance of friendships and
what it's meant to be in color to
wherever they are now developing new
connections and and why it's so
disruptive you know what we're dealing
with is massive disruption I saw you
talk with people about how the multitude
of responses that we have to this
disruption and instead of blaming your
kids are getting all angry that all they
think about is friends use this as an
opportunity to talk about friendship to
talk about your friends to talk about
the importance of community whatever it
is but there are really incredible
opportunities for deepening at this
moment that that is actually one of the
beautiful things happening people are
spending more time together
at the end of the day online they
actually don't want more online at the
end of learning the whole day for
distant learning on on their iPads they
don't want to watch another series at
night they actually want to play the
game so it's all these paradoxical
moments and you know I what I can tell
you is that the multitude of family
situations that has presented itself to
me in these two weeks it's just
mind-boggling how are you gonna deal
with the shuttling of the children with
your ex you know who do you think has
not been protecting themselves enough
how do you deal with you know the the
person who just began dating someone but
they suddenly are living together
because you know they what disruption
and impending disaster does is it
accelerates everything it functions like
an amazing accelerator we all know that
and in the aftermath of disaster there
will be more babies more marriages and
more divorces you know it's either what
are we waiting life is short what are we
waiting for
let's make a baby it's either life is
short I've waited long enough
let's leave you know it's like you read
you are meeting a place where suddenly
your priorities get reorganized and the
superfluous gets thrown overboard and
you feel
you're touching the essence you know
that you don't know what's gonna be so
you want to really hone in on the few
things that matter to you a lot so I
have a lot of these kinds of
conversations with people you know
people telling me this is you know I've
not really had integrity for the last
few years and I feel like this is kind
of rum and alarm to me that I want to I
want to be more honorable again I want
to not just think about money business
success etc I want to think more about
the people that matter to me and another
one who talks about you know I've been
wanting to be do art for so long and
this maybe is the opportunity for me to
to rethink what's important to me
there's a lot of rethinking what's
important to me at this moment then who
is important to me and there's a lot of
people calling their previous therapists
that's a classic thing that happens
around disaster it happened after 9/11
as well
people who reconnect with someone that
knew them in before and then people who
are calling people into Europe in Asia
you know who they haven't spoken to in a
long time and people are calling they're
talking they're not just texting they
want to hear voice all of that is
happening I'm giving you a bucket full
but it's a it comes at me as a bucket as
well mm-hmm well there's a lot to
there's a lot to explore in the bucket
and on one hand it seems like we have
these philosophical existential
questions we have this glimpse of
perhaps mortality that is often receded
in the background that allows us to see
the finite nature of our time that helps
to bring out the essence as you said and
then you have these these tactically
challenging situations for a lot of
people and you mentioned one that I
would love to highlight and get your
opinion on and that is someone who is
saying sharing custody with an ex and I
have a friend of a friend who so she
lives with her I think it's daughter
along with her elderly parents she
shares custody of that daughter with her
ex and her ex
is not being as careful as she is right
and is at least from her perspective
perhaps acting somewhat yeah
irresponsibly there in different
circumstances but she's very concerned
not for her own health necessarily not
even for her daughter's health
necessarily because but for her parents
exactly although although I mean I do
think just to point out that in the u.s.
at least a fairly high percentage of
those on respirators are forty-five and
younger so it's not entirely biased
towards the old entirely but but let's
for the time being just assume that that
they are at the greatest risk how would
you suggest she approach having a
conversation with her ex how would you
help someone like that if they were your
client try to navigate this maybe it's
not a conversation maybe it's something
else but how would you help someone in
that position navigate that okay I know
that our lives are very different and
that you really typically do things the
way that you do them and when our kid
comes to stay with you
I'm sorry I thought you're actually me
okay I got it so this is what you would
say to her I always do things the way I
do them you're right all right so sorry
could you just start over so my head
isn't like in I can't for you John okay
yeah John let's do John John first of
all tell me the age of the child leave
let's say Child's eight years old
okay so John you live the life she lives
and I'm in Norman a time when John comes
to you I trust you or I don't always
trust you but that has not impeded the
fact that that our kid stays with you
that he eats with you goes to school
with you drives with you a lot of things
that I typically would
do differently but you are who you are
and this is not me coming to ask you to
not be to change or to criticize you
this is me sharing with you that I feel
a tremendous sense of responsibility and
fear at this moment so the many people
that are living in my house and and
that's why I would like to ask you to
please collaborate with me would you be
willing to help me in this not because
you are scared not because you think
that washing your hands or doing all the
things that we're supposed to do is
important I'm not here to convince you
of any of that I'm just asking you if
you would be willing for my parents who
once we're your in-laws and who
hopefully that you still fancy or heaven
have liked as people all those years etc
I need your help I need us to put a few
ground rules down for the time being
because I can't do it without you that's
the hard thing to say so them day right
it's like the part of the divorces I
don't need you but here you're coming to
say I can't do this without you we are
still woven together in some way the
divorce is the end of the marriage but
it's not the end of the family and it's
a reorganization of the family and this
special circumstance forces us to
reorganize yet again to be more
interdependent than we usually have been
or want to be I don't necessarily want
it adult you want it either but if Jimmy
is gonna come back and forth
I need all his clothes washed I need him
to have one pair of shoes that goes
outside I need to know that you are
really careful no playgrounds no gyms no
you know whatever the things that people
have decided is their way of staying
really protected right and you asked for
it you don't tell them you don't
admonish them you know you may be right
but it's very unproductive approach
and you just show your fear your
vulnerability and the fact that you
really need them and you hope that they
will collaborate as best as they will
you won't see what they do behind closed
doors then you're gonna talk to your
eight-year-olds and you're going to say
there's a few things that you're gonna
need to do as of today without having
daddy or me remind you or tell you and
this is where people are needing to
brave talking with their children and
not just kind of you know try to
preserve reality as if it's business as
usual
and you tell you Rachel that Edie can
believe you may understand there's a
very there's a dangerous virus that we
are all trying to make sure that we are
protected against the best way we can we
probably all gonna have it we just want
to tell you that the level that is that
we can manage on our own basically and
here's what you need to do and then when
they come home the first thing you know
the whole thing but you you create a new
awareness and a new set of behaviors
that match the awareness that's how I do
it like you know it's a it's a it's a
real it's a very important one it's it's
actually one that I hadn't thought about
at first I wasn't until it came in front
of me and I said of course I did I
forgot that one it's like you know how
many versions of the story of kovat as
it pertains to relationships I am I
going to say oh I forgot this one I did
have the ones that are living apart and
can't meet I have the ones that are
living three generations in the house I
have the ones who are in the process of
divorce who are suddenly caught together
and and you know even a big house will
become really tight when you have to
still be together and you're on your way
go on I have the ones who've barely met
and I certainly living together I've got
and now came you know then I have the
same thing in a bigger version where
it's adult children in the divorce
situation and it's the adult children
who won't let the grandmother come and
see the grandchildren because she is in
another house with her new partner I
mean if this this thing has
many versions yeah many many different
permutations well let's let's talk about
thank you for answering that in such
detail and giving a template for people
at least an example of how you would use
language and let's let's talk about two
of the more common situations or at
least looking at the questions from my
audience it seems like two of the more
common groups so to people who are in
tight quarters together could be more
than two people but let's let's focus on
couples for now we could talk about kids
of course and then two people who are
separated so you have for instance from
Judith H she has how couples and
families can cope and give each other
space when they're quarantined together
and then Greg F as every tip she has for
long-distance romance asking for a
billion friends now
I want to actually modify this slightly
and borrow from another question for
Murad K which is what are her thoughts
on how to take advantage of this crisis
and the positive ways people are trying
to dot that I thought that that could be
anything but take advantage of this
crisis I think is a framing that I like
a lot you don't have to use it but as
that applies to two people together in
tight quarters or two people separated
and feeling separated how have you seen
people or advised people to sort of take
advantage of this crisis so there's a
lot lots of things that that I've told
about so the people together I mean it's
you know let's let's imagine they're in
the same space there is so a lot more
cooking going on people are cooking
they're not necessarily ordering out or
going out period so there's cooking and
the whole meaning of cooking it's like
it goes from the it's so long that I've
taken care of people like that to the
guy just in the in the session I just
did and it's like she came down for
lunch she cooked then she went to eat at
her computer and he just says you know
I would do the cooking just spend the 15
minutes with me I just want us to have
moments where we touch base with each
other where where you're not kind of
retreating completely into into your
computer so there is food then there is
human I think that humor is extremely
important in these moments there is
laughter inhale as my father or firm
used to saying they have their bad jokes
but there's a few of them that are just
really hilarious and when you crack up
like that at some of the things you you
receive some of the videos from abroad
that I get I it makes me feel so good it
just reminds me that I still can have
some perspective that I don't have to
just be constantly in the grip then
there is the critical conversations
about about mortality just simply
talking about are you scared
are you worried we're building a studio
I've given in a very personal a painting
studio for my for my husband and and you
know this is gonna be this is meant to
be Jack's next phase he's back into
painting and and so it's like you know
we talked about what that phase
represents what what would be lost if
you didn't get it about how eager and
how clearly is now that she has to get
there as fast as he can about about you
know he Britt one time he brought me a
shovel because he said you're already
digging my grave so why don't you just
start of course I cracked I was like you
know it so there is the humor there is
the creativity I think people need to
paint draw write homes play music sing
songs you know the arts I've helped us
throughout history to deal with
suffering to deal with fear to stay
connected to our loved ones that are far
away that are at sea all of that you
know people are making playlists sending
music dancing together through through
zoom you know it's it's all these
life-affirming what I call air hose you
know life of
firming experiences people are having
sex you know distance X's where people
are just laying in bed next to each
other
it's all happening typically but now
it's happening to people who don't
usually who haven't done it in a long
time
it's not that these are new behaviors
you know happy hours together drinks
reading out loud to each other it's very
interesting that the the kinds of stuff
that people are willing to do you know
these devices like the first time you
said we're gonna have a conversation
we're gonna talk about how our devices
are keeping us apart and today we're
talking to talk about how the very
devices that have kept us apart are the
ones that are keeping us connected Chris
like in in a very short amount of time
now they can do both they can keep us
much more lonely and in the vortex of
the digital as well but for many people
it really connects oh there's that then
there is you know the people getting
more and more reactive it's not you know
irritable and to just be able to
acknowledge I'm stressed I need to go
out this makes me crazy I don't get
enough movement I don't have enough air
I'm sorry you know and there's gonna
need to be a lot of that modulating and
moderating reactivity just and
acknowledging it is we know we know that
in situations of confinement attention
rises there is more fragmentation and
domestic violence ramps up I tell people
probably not good to drink don't get
don't get stew stoned and don't get and
don't drink these days it's not you know
it's not good if you get sick but it's
certainly not good at this moment
especially if you have a tendency to
drink more than you should and that you
are the version that becomes a line
rather than a donkey not a good idea
another good idea you know it's like
stock up on other stuff there is the you
know let the other person be yet their
way is just their way
it's it's you don't have you know it's
really about learning differentiation
accepting that the other person is
dealing with the same data from a
different stance and that you can't just
go ahead and think of them as they're
your threat you know then there is you
know some people have had to say maybe
this is the time to take the medication
that you've been trying to talk about
you know it will help you you know that
will level you just a tiny bit so that's
been not many times but enough times
where I just thought this is the moment
you know you need it now it's a take
care of yourself and don't just try to
be heroic in this particular moment and
then for the people who are apart I
think that a very important thing for
all people is really not to stay too
focused on the practicalities in general
I think long distance relationships do
better when people don't spend the
evening talking about the nitty-gritty
of days pretending that they have just
that they're living in the same life
they don't but really to connect around
more important things and take a walk in
nature together nature suddenly people
are walking more than you have a long
time you know you're talking about
virtually on something like FaceTime
yeah yes yes if walk with walk with
somebody and see them as you walk and
have them vote and they walk too you
know people walk up for one second yeah
so the the talking about more important
things and skipping the some of the sort
of mundane important yes but very kind
of surface level tactical did we
remember to restock cannellini beans or
whatever we're talking about our do
you've any questions or prompts or
anything that you might suggest to
couples
help the brides by who has been calling
you or reaching out to you I mean I'm
getting texts from people that I don't
usually hear from
you know other people that have
surprised other people that you have
been meaning just to connect to it and
this mood this could be a good moment
you know that's a very big one these
days that people talk about you know
this one spent some time in Italy ten
years ago and finds herself suddenly
talking with people that she knew back
then you know I think that's an
interesting one how how is your family
you know how are the different members
of your family I learned in the last
week of friends of mine and people I
knew that had siblings who were living
in residential treatment centers with
people who were in in jail people who
were homeless people wearing vulnerable
situations I never even knew these
siblings existence I mean it's like wow
you know you're telling me they you know
are or or things about family situations
that I didn't really know I kind of had
a sense but and so don't be scared to
ask more and just say tell me about your
brother tell me about your sister tell
me about your you're mentally ill you
know whoever and how are they dealing
who takes care of them you know tell me
about your your your for older people
you know if I'm not that old enduring
their 60s and early 70s not all you know
about with Alzheimer tell me about those
people that you can't go visit you know
tell me about it's this it's it's it's
it's going with the next question rather
than to stop and just say what has
surprised you you know what's the
thought of the day for you
you know what's the thing that really
marks your day to day you know what have
you noticed that you don't usually pay
attention to any more things like that
it's not just death and deepen and
disaster but it's it's just more
conscientious more attentive what we
like to talk about as present I don't
know if that's the word I would always
like to use but just more people are
asking how are you in ways that they
don't typically ask and they actually
want to know people are signed
their texts differently they're taking a
moment to check in even work meetings
before people get into the meeting they
kind of take a moment to just say how
are you how is everybody any news
it's just there is a kind of solidarity
or kind of thinking about well-being of
others that is in the air in a moment
like this allow it don't think it's you
know don't think you're being intrusive
don't think it's it's not productive
because we've got business to take care
of this is the moment to do all of that
let and let me let me play foil for just
a second if you ask someone and I'm
guilty of this too in answering in the
following way how are you and someone
says families safe all things considered
work is how are you right and so that's
the answer right which has become a bit
of a among a lot of my friends who feel
like they shouldn't complain for
instance I've known yeah they have no
right to complain because no one in
their family is sick therefore all
things considered everything's great and
then they move on to the next order of
business what would you ask to follow up
that question or how would you respond
to me how are things and I'm asking how
are you yeah that's a great response you
know you just saw I am so glad to know
that the facts are in place how are you
you know people who don't think they
were allowed to their feelings because
they have it good are usually add more
at risk what do you mean by that because
when they then have a feeling they don't
know what to do with it because they
shouldn't have it
they shouldn't currently be afraid they
shouldn't currently being shows they
shouldn't currently be depressed I
shouldn't currently be sad they
shouldn't currently agree because they
have a big house so because their friend
is healthier because they have the money
that you know they're not at risk of
losing their job that's okay so that's
not your worry that doesn't mean how are
you you know and sometimes I ask it
again I said okay that was that was your
that's your first degree about so now
I'm gonna ask you again
just tell me something how did you sleep
are you sleeping
are you eating I
you tasting the food are you I mean I
think that a lot of people who don't
have feelings don't sleep you know they
don't tell you I'm feeling bad they just
tell you I haven't slept very well well
and then I say you know are you the one
so this is one of my work it might make
only exist you know in a deep eg I'm I
say and he hadn't slept he overslept on
meeting this morning I said you don't go
to sleep or you wake up we said no I
woke up I said what happens at four
o'clock in the morning what was it like
for you you know do you what were you
thinking about what you think got you up
you know it kind of caught up with you
you know you've been trying to kind of
think I have it all under control and
then suddenly you know the night terror
arrives and we just chatted for three
minutes it's not like I don't do therapy
sessions with every person I meet but I
I can tell you once we had gotten that
you know address then we could actually
talk about what we needed to talk about
rather than you know him rallying up and
just kind of showing up to to be
disheveled you know ready for work
no you had a miserable night and that
warrants a minute of acknowledgement so
people who tell me all is good I say
tell me more you know how do how do you
get there I wish I could have a little
more of that myself on occasion what
happens when you say that to your
partner or to your to your the people
you living with you know do you do are
you the one that's in the role of being
the person who has to cheer everybody up
you know or I have on occasion asked my
asked two or three people that that gave
me answers like this and I just said is
that a role that you've had your whole
life that's a very good one you know is
that is that the typical way that you
are allowed to cope I could also just as
you're talking I also thought it could
at least with a lot of my friends if I
said if I said how are you doing they're
like all the things are considered great
everything's great now I would say and
so how are you and they're like good
if I said if I were to ask your wife how
are you how you're doing what would she
say I don't really get a much more
accurate answer and then sometimes you
just say what does it take for you to
get the permission to not have to
emphasize the word great you say that
one more time I think that's amazing
what does it take for you to finally
have the permission not to have to
emphasize great that would take me a
while to chew on how do you know yeah
how do you how do you answer that though
I don't want it to be what is the sound
of one hand clapping type of qohen
when you think about that question how
do you answer that for yourself or maybe
it's not an issue and therefore it's not
a question worth asking but I'm not
always feeling the pressure of being
great and I have arranged but I know
that people who have the pressure to
feel great have also the pressure to
make sure that they don't feel nothing
small like nothingness on the other side
of great is often depression and
nothingness right I see you're saying
right it's not it's not great at this
moment yeah I mean you're out of touch
with reality if you're feeling great
you can feel relieved you can feel
thankful you can feel a pretty you know
appreciative for what you have you can
feel humble you can feel thankful to
things but you can't feel great in this
moment because if you're feeling great
in this moment you detached you know
you're disconnected that's really what I
I would say but you know I I just I also
know that some people don't feel
internally that they have the permission
to feel anything but great on top of
things
in control in charge I goddess I got
this you know no you got nothing you
don't you know let me tell you something
after 9/11 the people who came down the
tower and lived with a worldview that
[ __ ] happens
did a lot better
and we're a lot less likely to
experience PTSD than the people who came
down the towers and live with the
worldview that says you're in charge
destiny is in your hands
yeah that's that makes perfect sense to
me you understand it's like well it does
it's the humidity ultimately gives you
flexibility the great when things then
when bad things then happen when [ __ ]
hits the fan to someone who must be
great even at the moment when it's
impossible to feel great it breaks them
hmm
and that's what I'm saying to people I'm
not turning them into mush or anything
I'm just saying it's okay it's okay not
to feel great in a time like this you
know it's either your work your health
the market the economy the vision for
the future the you know I am much more
okay when I say to someone how you're
doing and it says I've been working very
hard I want to make sure the company
doesn't go under I want to make sure I
have a guy I spoke to two days ago he
just laid off 200 people out of 204
that's that's a conversation and I said
to him oh this was an amazing moment so
I you know I'm girlfriend of his wife
and she's we were chatting and I was
actually quite upset in that moment in
the NA and then she told me this and I
said hey I pick up the phone and I said
I just want you to know I know how much
you care about your workers I can't
imagine what a hard thing that must have
been for you to do and I know I mean
this I haven't seen this guy cry ever
he's on the phone I didn't see I heard
it I knew it
it's just I just you know and I also
know that they're two or four and that
even though it looked like you're
protected you're not because it's not
yours but then he starts talking to me
I've never seen this man talk so much I
called every one of my managers I I mean
it was so heart-wrenching
you know it was honorable it was hard it
was done with integrity and and then the
next thing I get a text on her I said
you don't understand what you just did
you know it's like you just know exactly
what to say and the thing was I know how
hard this must have been for you hmm
that's when I said deepening the
conversation I could have talked about
you know how much money their company
has and I could have talked about other
things that's but it's not important at
this moment really this guy just let go
200 people who you know won't have jobs
that after that you stay quiet like you
and me I stay quiet that's not like this
you just let it sink for a minute yeah
yeah there are a lot of really difficult
decisions difficult conversations
difficult actions that have taken place
in the last week will happen this week
and will continue certainly beyond that
and you mentioned disconnected or
feeling disconnected a bit earlier I'd
love to talk about if we could for a
moment people who are living alone or in
quarantine alone I know that I know
friends who are practicing or by mandate
in isolation at home by themselves do
you do you have anything you've learned
with your patients that you could pass
on to those people I can't personally
imagine being alone right now I do very
even though I spent the majority of my
life isolating myself which not terribly
surprising also suffering with bouts of
depression now that I've become over the
last five years a more social creature I
find the prospect very daunting of
having of being alone during this time
and I would love to know what you would
say or what you do say to those people I
am so I America I was literally looking
I just got a message from one of my
close closest friends who lives alone
okay I think that there are people who
live alone but they're not lonely
they're connected they have a circle of
friends they have family friends
whatever they have a never a network or
a system support system and they chose
possibly for all kinds of reasons or
they have to to not to to quarantine by
themselves and for those people I
basically say keep everything as vibrant
as you can you know have dinner with
other people it's very interesting you
know online online everything online of
course but a few times a day make sure
that you've had you know that you've
touched base with people right right and
handwrites
actually if you can and then just
picture take a picture of it and send I
think it is a very interesting moment to
actually bring back some of the you know
our earlier
epistolary exchanges you know before you
just send another email but I think that
the distinction for me is between people
who are alone and lonely or people who
are lonely and not even alone and people
who live alone I think I want to
distinguish that the ones I'm the most
worried about are the people who are
lonely and who are I have nobody to call
and not many people checking them call
texts as a matter but to reach out those
I'm very worried about I'm worried about
depression
I'm worried about alcoholism I'm worried
about suicide and worried about a lot of
I'm worried about you know just and
living in a in an endless world of porn
whatever it is disconnected it's just
there's no one to reach out to them and
we this is not new even before the
digital you know when things like that
keeps you away from others so the best
thing I've found for those people is to
say go volunteer you know people need
you maybe but you don't see that enough
people love you but I can tell you
there's an a world of people out there
who need you at this moment
and who could use you bringing food for
them or go get their meds or walk their
dog or god knows what purpose a sense
that you matter a sense of social
relevance is gonna be the most important
thing and it's always is but it is even
more so now against that kind of
loneliness because when you lonely you
begin to question do i matter and what's
the difference if I'm here or not and
who even cares who would notice and it's
against that that I make people go
outside if you if you don't care that
much anyway then you can take some risks
but your risks will give you mental
health and your mental health will
ultimately help you with your physical
health because being healthy is not just
not having a virus you know being
healthy is living connected to all kinds
of things in the world nature people you
know work art but purpose is the peace
so I've made lists of all kinds of
volunteering that exists and extended
around to everybody who I thought would
really use it at this moment or should
use it could could I get a copy of some
of those I don't know if they're really
specific geographically but it would
that be something that I could put in
the show notes for this episode you a
lot of things I mean you know my
neighbor is the babe is the one that is
the easiest I think it's called my
neighbor right it's it's a because it's
my neighborhood and is it that that's
the name of it I don't I don't know but
I will I will tell people that we will
put these resources in the show notes so
if you just go to Tim da blog forward
slash podcast and that way York but they
must be everywhere like I have a friend
who runs a shelter for domestic violence
I have another person I know who what
works in a residential treatment center
all these places need people that will
come and work with the people who live
there and this
I mean it's endless actually it's a very
interesting thing there's no there's
gonna be less work but there is actually
an enormous amount of people needed
first for things I will send you the
ones I have they are primarily mostly
New York based but I
should they have been spread around the
country there's two young kids who
basically gathered thirteen hundred
volunteers in the city to just deliver
food to the elderly those who are trying
to stay home and don't necessarily know
how to connect with instacart you know
or don't have kids who will do that for
them I mean they you know walking dogs
going to get their meds taking them to
the doctor people still need to go to
the doctor you know there's still other
health issues and these two young kids
in their 20s gathered 1,300 people in a
few days and I made sure that two people
I work with who I thought you are not
rotting away like this you know get up
and go help you know I didn't say it
like this but this I really think that
if you don't feel that your life is
important enough for you sometimes it
helps to know that at least it makes a
difference for others and the phrasing
that you used earlier I thought was very
powerful and correct me if I'm wrong but
it was even if you feel that people
don't love you or wouldn't love you or
couldn't love you there's still plenty
of people who need you yeah I think
that's very strict thats very very
powerful to let sink in I think that's I
think that's a very strong wedge in the
door that can that can open the room
just a crack to let in a few rays of
light needs and from that point it's
like I think of this other person I was
working with Lester again you know she
was she's on her own now she said but
she's she's divorced whatever for a long
time but she also broke up with the new
with a new partner and there was this
kind of nostalgia of I don't have a
partner and meanwhile there are a lot of
other people around who actually would
be there so I think it's also important
to identify with people who is in their
circle and to do a social mapping you
know who actually does think of you but
you don't value it enough because it's
not
that it's not your partner it's not a
boyfriend a lover you know it's not
romantic and so and that's an important
piece as well is to actually broaden the
definition of who's there for you I you
know I draw a lot from my memories
around the AIDS epidemic from my work
around 9/11 from my own personal history
from from the Gulf War that you know I
mean there's a there's a lot of the AIDS
epidemic for sure there's a lot of
situations where we've learned a lot of
things it's not like this is the first
time that we we have to invent
everything peer connection is probably
the most important thing that will help
us in terms of mental health at this
moment parent groups people you know
men's group continuing online people
sometimes it's just basically activity
based it's fine it's fine it's at least
you know because why is it so important
because in this moment when you live in
your home like this and and your
especially if you don't have much space
the disruption is in space and in time
you know people have a rhythm they're
used to going out they come in alone or
with partners they know when they are
together when they are apart when even
with kids when the kids are away when
the house is their own and none of this
structurally nothing is actually
sustained at this moment so it demands
tremendous adaptability tremendous
adaptability in very very short amount
of time and people who are alone in that
sense or live alone or have less
adaptability in that sense their life is
actually more similar to the way that
they've lived it except that they can't
move themselves the way they used to
move but in terms of what happens inside
their space there's not that big of a
difference
yeah I've seen certainly for my
girlfriend at least that group exercise
classes online have F have had a
profound impact on her ability to
function
thrive on a daily basis whether that be
group exercise or dance classes mm-hmm I
think there's a site if you're
interested in hip-hop dance I think it's
called skeezy I have no idea how to
spell this gaggle but dancing is
extraordinarily important at this moment
more even than exercise because you
can't dance and be sad you know you can
listen to music and cry you can read and
cry you can draw and cry but you can't
dance and be and cry the body won't let
you I'm just trying to imagine what that
would look like I remember somebody sent
me like a a a kind of like a crying
combination smiley emoticon recently and
I was so confusing to me so yes dancing
and crying seems difficult to combine no
because the body that is collapsed
cannot dance so dancing is actually very
important and there's a lot of people
they put music together they put songs
the dolls together their talk at the
same time I mean it's actually very
imaginative and resourceful how people
are doing everything to to stay
connected to stay to feel energized to
feel you know vital what has helped you
what have you done so she does the
exercise classes and you well I do a few
things and it's evolved over the last
four weeks as I've realized what seems
to help and what doesn't seem to matter
at least personally so I I will say that
I have no delusion that this is normal
as it was say the same normal two months
ago and nor will it be the same two
months from now
I don't think certainly economically
that will not be the case and I have
found structure and routine to be very
very helpful for me because I am
bombarded all day with requests for help
text updates data etcetera that reflects
such a high degree of uncertainty and
unpredictability that it's very helpful
to have certain parts of
the day that are predictable for me and
there so among other things like my
girlfriend and I up to this point I
would say up until a few weeks ago woke
up at very different times she would get
up very early I would get up a few hours
later and we would work respectively
during the day meet up maybe we go out
to dinner maybe we eat at home
oftentimes we would have different
social engagements so it might not eat
together that's all changed
so we've we're now waking up around the
same time 7 o'clock or so 7:30 we are at
least most recently exercising together
we're not actually following the same
workout she'll be doing her dancing or
yoga or using an app for different types
of calisthenics I'll be doing something
called well there are a few things I
rotate through there's something called
the happy body by Jersey and on yella
Gregor ik that's a whole mouthful but if
you search the happy body and Gregor ik
gr e g o re k you'll find what I'm
talking about I did a podcast interview
with with Jersey as well it's
effectively a very short morning
mobility sequence it's very low impact
and I find that it undoes a lot of the
damage that's sitting with a laptop or
multiple screens for a good portion of
the day can inflict so wake up exercise
together which has really been
surprisingly impactful for us then at
that point the phone is also on airplane
mode I have to I've been trying to put
my phone on airplane mode around say 8
p.m. and to take it off of airplane mode
only after breakfast otherwise you're
just getting assaulted with bad news
24/7 then this is going to be just give
me a minute because it's up some of this
might be helpful to folks so this is
then I'm also ensuring at least when it
is allowed to walk at least an hour a
day try to get sunshine
and if I can't do that I actually have a
chest freezer that has been modified and
caulked some of this can still be done
even in places where there's some
restriction and movement so that I can
use a cold plunge so I'm using a lot of
cold and even a cold shower during the
day for some type of physiological
change at night this is one of the
bigger changes as you mentioned we're
cooking at home every night and it'll
sometimes cook for multiple nights at a
time but when we eat even if we're not
cooking we've actually chosen a
different table in a different room
because my girlfriend has in an office
here in the house I don't I would
usually go downtown to an office and
work but I can't do that at this point
or I'm not willing to do that so the
kitchen table has become my office and
the last thing I want to do is sit at
the kitchen table and have dinner so
we've moved a smaller really small table
low small table to the living room and
we sit down and we make a ritual out of
dinner and we'll set out the placemats
and we'll use the folded linens and
we'll open the door so that will close
the screen but can hear some nature
outside and we'll light a candle and say
a grace say we're grateful for and eat
together no devices and at that point we
usually go for a walk after dinner with
the dog because Molly requires outside
time for bathroom and otherwise and come
back and at that point usually try to
avoid devices and we have it we have a
television series that we watch during
the week which right now is the amazing
mrs. Mazal which is a fantastic show and
then we watch something else on the
weekends so that we are distinguishing
between the weekdays in the weekends so
we deliberately change our routines and
activities on the weekends so that
there's some feeling of a break such
that it's not Groundhog Day every day
also use heat exposures so my girlfriend
likes hot
Bath's I am very fortunate to have a
small barrel sauna and so I will use
heat at night and then I said the exact
that I needed to buy your so nothing
because it's actually one of the things
that they find to be very very useful
over over 56 degrees Celsius it's
actually it's very countering of the
virus and I really must be very helpful
and I said Jack again we need to get one
of Tim's asanas yep yeah they're
surprisingly I mean look I recognize
this is where I can get very judgmental
towards myself I recognize it's not
within the grasp of everyone but the at
least last I checked they sell
reasonably inexpensive barrel saunas at
Costco they did at least for a period of
time these are not this does not require
a year's salary necessarily but the
point being that we're using heat and
cold as contrasts through the day and we
find that to help with sleep also then I
usually foam roll a little bit before
bed because I'm still so spun up even if
I've done a lot of walking even if I've
done some exercise my mind is generally
still very very active so I will do some
foam rolling to try to down regulate and
then we'll go to bed and we use a
humidifier we also use or I use at least
a hot vapor device for just to try to
ensure upper respiratory tract or
support upper respiratory tract health
and that's the day there are and then
there are days where there's certain
types of other exercise like I might not
do the happy body and I might do peloton
for instance I use peloton quite a lot
and just seeing human faces on a big
screen is recorded or live doesn't seem
to matter for me is really really
helpful so I'll do that or on the bike
meaning the stationary bike will do
scenic rides so there these are this is
video footage of the Alps or New Zealand
or fill in the blank and that's more or
less the day and it's pretty much copy
and paste every day there's
there's less variance in my routine
right now than at any other time in the
last several years mm-hmm and I think
that is part of what is helping me to
stay mostly sane so that's a long answer
to a short question but I think that
many of these will be will be really
helpful and I mean you add a few things
to kick can I add one more before the
other the other thing that my girlfriend
and I have have done and this is
actually based on a conversation I had
with brené Brown not too long ago on the
podcast he spoke about how she does this
with her husband but we will tell each
other in the morning oftentimes we don't
do this every day but if we are really
worn thin maybe we didn't sleep well
like last night I couldn't stop thinking
I was physically exhausted but just had
that tired and wired experience where I
just could not ramp down and I had taken
a fair number things already to try to
help me sleep and it didn't matter so I
got probably two or three hours of sleep
last night and so I told my girlfriend
this morning I said I'm I'm probably at
about 20% just to give you a heads up in
case I'm overly sensitive mm-hmm I I
don't have a whole lot of slack in the
system right now I probably I have a
total of 20% in the tank and she does
the same so it could be that we're at 70
80 how are you doing I'm feeling really
good I'm at 90 had a full night of sleep
it's a beautiful day great and then
there are some days whether it's there
are hormonal contributions let's say
with menstruation and so on or could
just be related to sleep events news
from close friends and family etc that
we give each other an indication of how
much buffer we have in the system so
that our our behaviors are perhaps
easier to understand and also so the
other person can pick up the slack if
necessary and and make make more of a
make more of an effort for a day or two
yeah it's a that's very much what they
were saying
before when I said
you know if you're irritable if you're
low-energy if you it's basically kind of
let check in with each other do pulse
checks and let the other let each other
know where you are at so that your
responses are put in a context you know
and and and each one knows what they can
expect from the other I I think you've
given a really rich list you know I go
to nature I take hikes and I I have
certain paths where I can literally be
on the air I'll go alone every morning
or I will have somebody else call
someone and said you want to go right
and they drive to me and we walk up to
mountains but one person on each side of
the road so I actually am able to still
see people a few but but I have I have a
book club we have we have migrated
online and I have a movie club which is
the most beautiful thing because we
spend ninety minutes talking about films
every week we have to watch film and we
talk about it and for a while you talk
about something completely unrelated so
different with people who are in
Australia in France in here in the US we
are all over the place our little group
and it's been so nice so nice to just uh
ya know could you could you say more
about that just tell us more about the
format when you do it how does it work
what are the what are the rules of the
movie club ha we were about to start
this movie club because we'd had a book
club first for three years now and we
were just about to start a movie club
and this thing happened and we spread
out and so I said we want you know let's
not let it wait let's do it wherever we
are literally somewhere in Europe
somewhere in Australia one is in Hawaii
the others asked all over the US and
basically we decided on a movie
would you decide on well the first one
was Jojo Rabbit the second one was the
marriage of Maria Brown by Reiner
Fassbender which is a movie of 79 that
is phenomenal movie and the third one
that we're doing now is some
let me see
it's an American film another dumb dumb
and Dumberer no no no it'sit's something
it's AC film club in front stars in my
crown stars in my crown but stars in my
crown it's a one-person basically said
you know we highly recommended it and so
we we don't know what we're watching you
know one person shows a movie and and we
say let's go with it
so we meet 4 o'clock on Sunday because
that is a 6 a.m. or whatever this is
just that they're changing in Australia
and in Europe this week so we have to
make sure that this one isn't too early
and this one isn't too late and we are
in the middle three or four o'clock in
the afternoon on Sunday and we meet and
and we are about how much where we let
this time it be around 15 of us and some
of them two of them are in the same room
some of them are on their own and and we
discussed the film so you watch it
anytime you want
yes you watch it is it weekly or monthly
it's a monthly weekly weekly we were
gonna do it monthly but we moved it to
weekly because it just was so nice such
a we yeah that's a great idea that's a
good so you know so we often we've seen
the movie actually 1 or 2 days before so
it's fresh and one of us is the is the
the moderator that basically makes sure
that everybody gets a chance to speak
and you're using zoom for this or what
are you though and then this week we
have the book club which is usually once
a month and yeah once a week for the
book club is ambitious yes yes no plus I
can't read I mean I I feel like I do not
have enough of that concentration at
this moment so I haven't done my
homework for this Sunday what is what is
what was the assignment this month I
will tell you in a sec
book club next book clubs a dance to the
music of time by Anthony Powell hmm
don't ask me more I have I have not know
and if I don't read it I don't attend I
can't just be your calm just show up for
the sake of showing up you can show up
for the first 20 minutes when we are
checking in and having a drink and then
and then when people start a
conversation basically you say see you
next time
well is there is there a particular set
of questions that you go through for the
movie or is that are just a free-for-all
when you guys meet for the movie
check-in we we did it twice
you know um what would you know we start
sometimes with what you know whether
people who particularly loved it and
particularly did not ask why why did you
love it why did you hate it type thing
and then you never meet with me the
question was why did you choose it
why because I chose the one from from
last week why did you why did you choose
this movie what did you see then there
are some being you know there there's a
couple of people who know a lot about
cinema and they often know the work of
that director and then it's just really
a very interesting chat so what it's so
tell us your answer what which movie was
it last week and why did you trace it
the movie was the marriage of Maria
brown which i if you don't know
Fassbender you it is one of the most
important post-war German directors six
70s and it basically is the story of a
woman who is also the metaphor for
Germany so if a story told through this
one woman and her post-war life and how
she climbs and becomes this rich lady
and and her relationship to this man
that she married was she actually spent
one night with but spends her whole life
waiting for but in fact the story of
Maria Brown is also the story of how
Fassbender sees Germany post war so it
you have these two tracks being told
same time the story of a love story of a
woman but in fact it's the story of a
nation and that being able to tell two
stories at the same time of which one is
overt and the other one is hidden is
incredibly is incredible because it's
the cinematography the guy who was the
cameraman of Fassbender then after that
movie he moved to the states and he
became Martin Scorsese's favorite
cameraman I've heard of him yeah you
know so the feeling my photography of
the film is also just something you know
amazing and I didn't see this film since
79 I just remembered it as some as one
of those formative movies in my life and
and it follow Jo Jo rabbit so it kind of
had a logic as to why I I thought about
that and then our next movie will be
badlands terrence malick the one of the
greatest American directors so we're
just going it's it's very it's not very
formal II know it's like somebody says
it's to Malik Malik is an amazing
director to discuss and and so then we
decide which would be a good Malick
movie to see and then we we decided okay
let's do badlands because it's one of
the great American films and it's
exciting it's so nice to be talking
about something else for a bit you know
sorry to interrupt you said at the
beginning you do your your catch-up
introductory check-ins and have a drink
are there any rituals or rules around
that do you guys kind of cheers each
other are you all just kind of nursing
one drink no no it's in that sense it's
rather you know we are half Americans
and half from all over the world and the
people the from abroad tend to not want
this to be too structured like that it's
like you know we we don't really know we
session ends when we've said what we had
to say it's not like you know we say
from 6:00 to 8:00 it starts at 4:00 and
then this one it went in 5:30 and at
5:30 it feels like we have enough right
I like it I like it I like it you know
it was just like okay I guess we're
ready for the next film we've kind of
gone around the block everybody I said
what they have to say we've had our
discussions and it's good and then we've
had a few more minutes where people
checked in how are you where are you you
know what's it like in Australia you've
got the last plane you know people kind
of checked in with each other and then
we said see you next Sunday so that's
the that's been a real hi from me
actually I do yoga every morning with a
different leader its class I have two
unusual ongoing classes in the city and
I've just continued them online and then
I just check in every night with a
friend and I say you know do you want to
meet me at 7:30 for an hour because I
realize that I can't do it alone I don't
have the motivation if I do it alone
I'll do it for 20 minutes and then I'll
you know I'll get caught up with
something else my productivity level is
not at the same level in my discipline
either so if I'm accountable to someone
someone is waiting for me I'll be there
and I'll show up and I just text anybody
like that I send it out to a variety of
people and I just say are you free
tomorrow for yoga or for a walk you know
it's very impromptu in that way but I
realized that I do better with somebody
than alone at this moment and then I go
with my husband I say let's take away
let's just take a 20-minute walk before
we start sitting at a laptop the whole
day let's just walk together and we
haven't been to town or anything I
haven't I have not been outside of just
playing nature in that sense or even
walk around you know it's no this week
so we just walked around to the place
here in the neighboring streets it's not
it's not major but just just to hear you
know see skies like you son listen there
and what listened to a lot of music
I've actually been listening to a lot of
music in ways that I don't notice
background and I think your thing about
setting the table Jack did that last
night it was so good
you know he said the table by the you
know in a different room and put a can I
mean a ritual ritual of Kenneth let's
let's still it still feel that we can
settle in and and savor this whole even
if it's a half an hour you know that
just let's let's not just with
everything kind of you know unravel
around let's keep her sensors but it's
more than structure it's really a ritual
yeah I think rituals at this point are
extremely I extremely important like the
one that when you wake up in the morning
that's a ritual that you do would you go
first so I I am looking for different
rituals you know I definitely measure
and this I would say to other people I
know when I can't read one more article
about this I think I think I go past the
point I mean like you know you know I
can't I wasn't gonna listen to the daily
yesterday you know I was just like I I
get to briefing us you know I got my
list but I just know sometimes it's okay
I'm gonna go two days without it's fine
it's fine so that's the thing is just
it's okay to think about other things
and we have also done some watching of
TV together you know though I really
don't feel like having more screen time
at the end of the day I'm like you know
screened out so sometimes just sitting
quiet and listening to the out like you
with your porch just sitting outside
it's still cold here but just a quiet
because we talked a whole day is another
thing we talk we listen we are in
conversation with patients the whole day
and work you know I think we haven't
said much about that but I do feel
better when I work I feel that I'm not
and I feel that I have a sense of agency
that I can do things so I prepared a
keynote address last week for 1,300
people about couples in quarantine and
you know teaching my colleagues I I my
supervision group is usually monthly I
said we will need to move every week and
now I will enough hold the group it's 25
therapists together helping other people
to think about their work concerns doing
the podcasts I found it so creative to
be doing this podcast at this moment I
feel like and I'm I'm finding a way to
bring purpose and creativity together
and and I'm not thinking about myself
it's really that I just don't want to
spend all my time thinking about me and
my own little world and just feel like I
I can contribute do something for others
those are the things that I've worked
harder than I have done I mean it's an
incredible thing how I don't know even
know where it suddenly came from and you
know I live with my husband Jack who so
I say you well who happens to be a for
three decades an expert in disaster
preparedness so I forget whou and you
know I get it I hear the names the colds
you know this is very much in our house
the expertise of people who have worked
with large scale psychosocial trauma so
I go back and forth between wanting to
hear from him because he knows so much
and then kind of saying can we talk
about something else
you know but that so I think we were
very much on the same track in terms of
things things that that we do he
meditates every day I don't but I know
that that's very important that I do my
Yoga makes you want but meditation I've
been trying to run and put us and in
goal for myself that I will add ten
minutes every day to my run because it's
my uphill I try to still feel like I can
discover certain things that put little
challenges for myself rather than just
preservation well IIIi think we've I
think we've given people a lot to chew
on there's so many different things to
explore how to use music I've ended up
using you know classical during weekday
workday typically reggae at night on
weekday evenings and then different
music for the weekends and a whole whole
system we have we are vinyls behind here
so we are like every night we rediscover
music we haven't heard in years well
that's amazing
and and Esther you're amazing I always
love our conversations and it's it's
been actually a real nice decompress for
me just to have this conversation with
you and I how full your days are and I'm
thrilled that you're able to find time
to spend some of it in this conversation
and I I know people are gonna want to
learn more about you see what you're up
to listen to what you're up to where
would you like people to go what would
you like them to pay the most attention
to you have so many different projects
there's a few that I'm very much in line
with the moment so my newsletter and
blog I think is probably the most direct
place where I also give some of the
suggestions recommendations and you just
go to my website Esther Perel that come
and you sign on I mean that's that's
where I'm really putting together in in
small bites what I often develop in in
long form if you want so the newsletter
where should we begin we have a special
season that is couples in quality now
just to be clear I know I said it in the
introduction but the name of the podcast
is where should we begin question
correct correct
just making sure
my podcast where should we begin has a
special season of which the first
episode was dropped last night which is
a couple in Sicily it's called two
adults three children and a wall in
between I did the second one today we'll
do a series of that and then how is work
which I also am gonna do episodes for
how is work this is the first season is
out everywhere where you get your
podcast it's about the invisible forces
that shape workplace dynamics but it is
it is ever more relevant right now ever
more relevant so what I will do a few
episodes as well about issues around
work as they are presenting themselves
right now here and abroad
sessions is the platform where I work
with anybody who wants to be more
trained as coaches therapists all the
people who want to more get training
that's a digital training platform and
sessions is going to be the place
through whom I'm going to do training
for managers founders you know all of
that and and all the social channels you
know it's all integrated but I've always
worked on how people handle their
relationships and I think that health as
it relates to relational health and
mental health it's at the forefront of
what we talk and you don't get so much
of that when people are spending more
time about the virus itself health is
more than just not being sick so that's
what I want to emphasize in this moment
and that's where you find me Esther
Perel dot-com is the gate to it all and
then the podcast app wonderful Esther
Perel calm is the gate to it all folks
I'm telling you check it out she has a
just an incredible corpus of work and
you continue to put out yes the guy who
asked you what kind of things for people
who are living apart
I'm also rekindling desire which is the
the online workshop that I have that
really is for how you maintain
playfulness spontaneity curiosity in
your relationship
you can you don't have to be living
together at all to go through that and
it is jam-packed with suggestions of how
to maintain that connection a distance
as we say what was it called again
rekindling desire rekindling desire that
was actually almost verbatim another
question so you you answered a question
without even knowing it also a separate
question rekindling desire excellent on
the website it's a I mean I don't have
to say more just go check it out it is
what it says it is it is what it is it
is what it says and everybody out there
should try weekly movie club I think
that's a brilliant idea
I'm absolutely going to explore that
with a friend of mine and to see what we
can put together with our with our gang
and it's always such a pleasure Esther I
really appreciate you taking the time we
will link to everything in the show
notes and more specifically for folks
who want to see resources from this
episode to see our first episode which
has completely different content very
very very different looking at monogamy
non-monogamy all sorts of other topics
as well as the volunteer resources which
will be I think very important and
powerful for a lot of people who can
benefit from feeling needed right now we
will put those at Tim blog forward slash
Esther
so that's TI m dot dl OG /e s th ER so
you'll be able to find all of my
conversations with Esther as well as the
resources at that link and links to
everything that we have discussed so far
and I think that's a full conversation
for now thank you so much my dear
same thing here be well be healthy be
safe and all of you who are listening to
us I wish you really all the best and I
will echo that thanks to everybody for
tuning in and until next time be safe
former Movie Club
listen good music good music allow
yourself to dance I have to get that
there I have to find a way and they
connected people in one thing it's
so-called social distancing that's the
wrong word
you know it's physical distancing but
it's social meaning do not misunderstand
that word exactly and last but not least
be kind and that includes yourself
alright signing off thanks everybody hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me and would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
shipstation
I've been super impressed with these
guys shipstation is the shipping
software with the most 5-star reviews
now speaking as a former ecommerce CEO
back in a previous incarnation when I
was shipping tens of thousands and then
hundreds of thousands of products this
is what I wish I had way back in the day
as folks adapt to this changing world
these strange times we were all going to
be buying more
stuff online than ever before and if
you're an e-commerce seller or if you
want to be selling more online give to
ask yourself are you ready to meet the
demands of our new delivery economy you
can be ready with shipstation
and lots of my friends use them so why
shipstation when you're selling online
in a lot of orders out fast can be super
hard I've experienced this firsthand how
do you keep track of who gets what which
shipping carrier should you use how do
you process refunds how do you process
returns how do you do all of that are
you getting the best rates shipstation
helps online sellers of any size get
orders out quickly save money on
shipping costs and keep customers happy
they do a few things really really well
you can import more orders from more
places so no matter where you're selling
Amazon Etsy Shopify eBay your own
website wherever shipstation brings it
all into one simple interface making it
really easy to manage from any device
including
your cell phone your smartphone you can
instantly rate shop your favourite
carriers and this is a huge deal as a
shipstation user you can get access to
discounted rates that are typically
reserved for much larger companies like
fortune 500 companies that meet certain
minimums
just as an example shipstation just
negotiated a new deal with UPS which
rates are discounted as much as 62
percent that has a huge impact on
businesses and on your bottom line your
profit margin and an Amazon Prime world
where people are used to free shipping
small businesses or smaller businesses
can struggle to stay competitive with
high shipping costs shipstation can help
with that you go way beyond ordinary
tracking so there's a self-serve portal
for people who want to know where their
order is when they're gonna get it etc
returns ditto
self-serve it just makes everything
easier that's why shipstation is the
number one choice of online sellers
today you ship more product and less
time with the best rates available and
right now my dear listeners you can try
shipstation free for 60 days when you
use offer code tim p IM there's
absolutely no risk you can start your
free trial without even entering your
credit card info just visit ship station
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in Tim that's
shipstation dot-com then enter offer
code Tim shipstation dot-com make ship
happen one more time ship station comm
click on the microphone at the top and
type in Tim that's me t IM check it out
this episode is brought to you by magic
spoon I love these guys and I love their
products magic spoon is a brand new
cereal that is low carb high protein
zero sugar it tastes exactly like your
favorite cereals from your childhood
it just doesn't include all the bad
stuff that's the gist
so especially these days when I'm
looking for fond associations good
feelings you know back in the day when I
was before school watching scooby-doo
and eating these cereals that would
leave my milk some sort of
phosphorescent color those were good
times and now I can eat this cereal
which I haven't done in decades but I do
now regularly because let's face it
beans and pasta gets old after a while
so variety pays off each serving has 12
grams of protein 3 grams of net carbs 0
grams of sugar and only 110 calories
it's also gluten free grain free soy
free GMO free basically all the things
that you don't want free and it's
delicious comes in your favorite
traditional cereal flavors like cocoa
frosted blueberry you can try them all
by getting a variety pack at magics
food.com forward slash Tim and the way I
found out about this was actually
through a number of my friends one of my
friends and one of this podcast most
popular guests dr. Peter Tia has crushed
and I've seen this on Instagram and also
for 6 to 7 servings of this at a time
that's a lot of cereal with no glycemic
response in effect it was sugar remained
flat he was so impressed with the
results of his self experiments that he
ended up investing in the company that's
true for two other friends as well Kevin
rose and Ryan holiday so check it out
see what all the buzz is about you can
go to magic spoon comm board / Tim to
grab a variety pack and no need to take
just my word for it magic spoon has
received a lot of attention since
launching last year Time
included in their list of best
inventions of 2019 and Forbes called it
the future of cereal and my listeners
that's you get free shipping direct to
your door so you don't have to go out to
buy this and a 100% happiness guarantee
so if you're not a fan you don't love it
they'll give you a full refund no
questions asked just use code Tim I've
been stocking up on this and I know
bunch of my friends are as well let's
check it out
magic spoon calm forward-slash Tim one
more time that's magic spoon calm
forward-slash Tim and free at least
check it out for a really really
well-done website but the product is
even better than the website I promise
you that so check it out
you
you
you
you